-In a 46-minute video
he posted on his Twitter
and Facebook last week,
President Trump
once again claimed
that last month's presidential
election was rigged.
Here to talk about it is one
of our writers, Jeff Wright,
in our segment "The Wright Thing
with Jeff Wright."
♪♪♪♪
-What it do, Seth and the
good people of the world?
-So...Jeff, what do you thin
of the president's last post
-I felt a lot of ways
about the president,
but, when I saw that new post,
I realized
I'm jealous of him, Seth.
-Really, you're jealous?
-Yes!
He does what he wants,
says what he wants,
offends who he wants,
and 74 million people
still like him.
-Yeah, but I'm pretty sure
there's 80 million people
who beg to differ.
-74 million, 80 million.
You know how many people
like me?
-I don't know.
-Eight.
Actually, seven,
because James is mad at me
for not texting him back,
but it's like I get busy.
But the truth is
I'm not that busy.
It's just James isn't
that fun to text with.
-Really, you're that jealous
-Yes!
Trump may have lost
the election,
but Trump is unbeatable, Seth.
He's treating America like it'
a game of "Grand Theft Auto"
and, far as I'm concerned,
he's beating every mission
-You really think so?
-Yes!
The man even beat
the COVID mission!
If this was really
"Grand Theft Auto,"
Trump and his friends
would have at least five stars
and still not even be arrested
And, even if they did
get arrested,
he would just pardon them.
I'm really jealous of that
Imagine being able
to pardon people.
-Oh, so, if you could
pardon people, you would?
-Damn right I would!
In fact, I'd start with me
because I took
your cup of pencils
and replaced it with a sandwich.
-Wait, you did what?
-Took your pencils,
but it's okay.
As they say in the White House
pardon me.
-Oh, that's not how that works
-[ English accent ]
A thousand pardons, good sir
-No, not at all.
But, Jeff, you shouldn't b
jealous of Donald Trump
because he's -- So, wait,
you took back your sandwich?
-No, I took your sandwich.
I'm sorry,
but blatant wrongdoing
is part of the Trump plan.
And for that,
may I truly be pardoned.
In the name of the pardon,
the other pardon,
and the holy pardon.
-Jeff, I'm now pretty sure
you have no idea
what pardoning is
and I can't believe
I'm saying this, but,
you shouldn't just run aroun
acting like the president.
-Of course I should!
We all should!
Just make stuff up
and pretend it's the truth
Did you see when Trump
brought out his little graph
You can tell a graph is the only
way they explain things to him
He's a visual learner, Seth.
Which is a polite way of sayin
he can't read.
-Did you believe his graph
-Oh, no!
But I like that he did.
And I think a graph
convinced a lot of people.
That's why I came
with my own graph, Seth.
See, this graph right here shows
why I deserve a raise, okay?
This line represents
America's happiness
before I got on your show,
and this is its happiness after.
It's an overnight surge
of happiness, Seth.
-Did you just
make that up yourself?
-Yeah, I did.
Just like he did.
And I even bought a Sharpie,
because everyone knows
a permanent ink marker
makes it official.
You know what?
I'm going to give myself
a raise.
-How much money are you
giving yourself per year?
-$500 million.
-$500 million?
Come on, Jeff, that's crazy.
-Crazier than Trump
this past election?
-Ah, fair point.
-And I'm going
to give myself a PS5,
because I deserve it, Seth
Look, all I'm trying to say is
Trump has had a run
no one could see coming.
How many presidents can sa
they've been impeached,
pardoned their friends
who have committed crimes,
and still finished a full term
Truly inspirational.
-I guess that's one way
to look at it.
Jeff Wright, everybody.
-Pardon me?
-Oh, no, sir, pardon me.
♪♪♪♪